i mean for for me it's just like another
thing is as well is that i think i just
suck at shopping i i i like
if if shopping was a ranked game i'd be
bronze level no i'd be [ __ ] iron man
like so like me and shopping i would be
rock i would just be a star like like me
in shopping gift giving aside like gift
giving aside me and shopping is
when i shop i know exactly what i want
and if i don't know what i want i'm i'm
so [ __ ] lost i go i go to a store and
i'm just like i i try really [ __ ]
hard like because i'm so bad at
knowing what my friends want yeah and
that's why i struggle a lot but i i just
spend like a lot of time just thinking
like yeah like all right well god
mentioned this gone man okay well you
know god's kind of into this
you know so kind of like kind of like
run through things in my head i'm like
i've got to buy you something that you
would never buy for yourself that you
would appreciate someone else buying you
yeah it's kind of how i do gifts yeah
you know meanwhile for me it's like i
have to stop myself from texting god
saying what do you want
what do you want for your birthday i'm
also not against that if someone wants
to ask me like if someone is like what
do you want i'm like just saying jojo
but there are people who are like super
against that though
you know i'm on i'm kind of in the
middle of this i'm like i really
appreciate giving gifts and the whole
act of it but also i understand that
sometimes you can't give gifts sometimes
you you don't want to give gifts
sometimes you don't know the person well
enough so you want to figure it out but
you want to say that you're like hey
i i appreciate you being a cool friend
or whatever but i don't know you very
well but you're you're cool somebody buy
something i don't know what you want or
yeah no because like i i do like the
feeling of giving a gift and i do think
about every gift i think uh every gift i
give which is that like the issue for me
is i just it's a skill that i suck at
yeah i i really really
i i i honestly really suck at it which
is why like i it's
when it comes to the point which is
christmas where i have to give gifts i'm
just like i'm [ __ ] myself i'm just
like yeah well [ __ ] me man
it's i have to i have to do shopping for
other people and i suck at shopping for
myself and i'm just like well [ __ ] i
yeah one thing i've i've come to
understand as an adult about gift giving
and this is something you this is an
easy trap to fall into if somebody's
really into something right yeah and
they talk about it a lot like i do this
yeah my hobby and stuff right it's
really easy to think that like oh i can
just i can just buy something to do with
that hobby right yeah that'll work out
right yeah and that's like a terrible
idea because if you don't understand the
hobby as well as they do you're probably
not buying something that's like as
useful as you think yeah
yeah because they probably have a vast
knowledge of the said thing yeah and
it's also a problem when like the the
hobby that they're talking about is also
the collection that they follow right so
yeah yeah so every time like aki's
birthday or christmas rolls around and
she and i'm like oh i can just buy her
something kingdom hearts related and
then i remember she literally has
everything kingdom hearts i'm like what
the [ __ ] it's just like if
if if you want to buy something for them
in that collection if they already don't
own it then yeah and that's such a
rarity right yeah it's it's not going to
happen because they probably if
if they don't have something that they
already own they already know they don't
own it and maybe they've already tried
to get it and they can't and if you
can't get it then that's an um that's a
[ __ ] bang a gift that's happened a
few times before and i'm just like [ __ ]
yeah man and i can't i can't wait
because you know sometimes sometimes you
just buy a gift and you just you just
can't wait to give it right you know
you're just like
i and that's what that's what's so
magical about gift giving but my problem
is that it's so rare to find that one
[ __ ] gift that [ __ ]
you [ __ ] nail out of the park and you
just [ __ ] you're [ __ ] excited to
give it and it's it's so hard and uh
that's why 99 of the time i just i suck
and i want to do better what do you do
what do you normally go for what i
normally go for wine
what did you get me last year i don't
remember what you got me
oh i i is this am i a bad friend for not
remembering i mean both of you don't
remember
so it must not have been anything
i remember i remember even uh tin uh tie
thing like the it's like the oh the type
in right there
yeah yeah yeah yeah
because i remember
the last gift i got you which was the
wine decanter
oh thank you very much and i remember
you got me uh i mean that was for your
birth name for your for my birthday you
got me a cigar holding case yeah the the
firing box i i got you a kirin art
[Laughter]
yeah i got him a cure and i figured out
because i remember that was the first
gift i gave you guys for the first
christmas which was i remember i got you
the jojo figures yeah yeah yeah that's
right um yeah
it's hard it's it's hard it is hard
because i was like i was like i don't
know i you know it's like i know god has
a vague interest in this thing i don't
think he's too too in deep in it so yeah
i think i can buy something to push the
hobby a little more
it's it's scary because like yeah as you
said like if it's something that you
know they're really into
and it's like what what how are they
going to feel if i get them enough
because i want to give them something
unique yeah i want to have something
unique i want to give them something
where it's like they will look at it and
go oh i remember when joey gave me that
yeah but i'm so hard i'm jealous of like
like whenever i see melin gives gifts
like maylin's just like [ __ ]
[ __ ] like challenger rank s tier gift
giver man like sometimes she gives gifts
to sydney and i'm just like [ __ ] why are
you gonna why you going to demon like
this man
give me a jojo umbrella that was really
good i always wanted one yeah i mainly
knew i wanted one so she said bailey
just knows right like happy birthday
just like melinda knows all like where
to get all like the cool things you
wouldn't normally think about and i'm
just like
how like meanwhile for me i'm like i
look on amazon it's not there i get it
i'm like i'm like melee and teach me
like like
a pool
a whole pedal yeah yeah definitely sorry
sorry
i don't know what i was gonna say i
dropped it
the poor etiquette of trash taste what's
the most you've ever spent on a gift or
ever received
i got my mama phone i know plane tickets
oh yeah yeah yeah
i bought my dad uh
[Music]
i bought my dad like a ten thousand
dollar like car engine oh my god jesus
yeah because he was like because he he
has this like 1960s like beetle like a
vintage beetle car because he loves
vintage cars
mama ferrari too as well
and uh and he was like son
always starts his emails with son hello
son
uh may i borrow some money for you from
you uh to buy this like engine because
i'm trying to rebuild this beetle and i
realized like that was the moment where
like i realized i hadn't really like
given a lot of gifts to my dad growing
up or anything like that and you know
it's always been like small stuff and
you know it's it's you usually get to
that age where you like you really start
to appreciate your parents especially
when you're not living with them all
right so i was just like i'll just give
it to you just just you don't have to
give me back the money i've never seen
my dad cry
that was the moment he cried and he was
like and he was like everything that's
uh in my will uh aimed towards your
sister i'm rewriting it
so you get the he's like he knows he's
like you get the record collection you
get you get all the stuff my sister's
like what the [ __ ]
give give dad 10 grand yeah
10 grand gets the whole wheel
big brain big brain yeah
i think that was the most honest man but
like i i feel that but that's like a
gift though that i feel was like long
overdue like that wasn't just one gift
that was like a collective gift for like
all the years yeah i mean i feel like
i've given my parents some pretty big
gifts as well and that was just because
i just wanted to show my gratitude yeah
or
just [ __ ] raising me and hopefully
raising me right thank you very much mum
and dad
yeah because i don't think i gave that
to my dad for like a birthday or
anything he's like he just i was just
like you know what just take it yeah
yeah because like that was that was the
time there was those are the gifts i
feel where you can't wait to give away
you know and yeah i remember i
i've also luckily i've i i've had a
moment where i've also made my parents
cry from happiness as well or maybe
hopefully shed it's in i'm just like
damn that's the best feeling that that
is that that is the best feeling that's
the best feeling yeah i remember i
remember the probably the most
surprising gift i got actually was a ps4
from sydney and uh i remember this was
back when
she did she had just we had just started
dating so she wasn't like working or
anything or she was kind of working like
part-time jobs or whatever odd inside
but uh she barely had any money to
support me so at the time you know
i wasn't expecting too much from from
her and uh
uh we celebrated christmas at their
place and she um she gives me like all
the small presents and then she goes
there's one more thing
and there's always one more there's one
more thing i'm like what are you what
are you talking about well how can there
be one more thing sydney i know
like i know you don't make any money
okay like like you know i send that
account
and uh and uh and and she and she brings
out she brings out this massive box i
was like
what is this what what is going on and i
open it up and it's a [ __ ] ps4 and
like at that time
at that time
we we weren't doing so well okay so i
like i was i was [ __ ] [ __ ]
aghast is that where i was flabbergasted
i don't know i was i was [ __ ] shocked
you know i was like
it was the first time in my life that i
think i was like truly just speechless
and i remember she she keeps telling me
about that one moment that she gave me
that gift
she's she's still chasing that
she's
she tries to like one-up herself we both
try to like reach that moment where we
give the gift that just like stuns the
other person and she keeps talking about
that one moment and like she's she's
chasing her yeah you think doing cocaine
is good
give your loved one a gift they don't
expect that that was that was me when
aki gave me the the giant berserk figure
oh man
that was when i was like that's a keeper
right there boys she knows what i want
yeah how the [ __ ] does she even hide
that gift from you oh she didn't oh okay
so it arrived like like i think like two
weeks before my birthday and i'm like i
don't know how she was trying to hide it
from me because i opened the door
and there was
seven giant [ __ ] like boxes
yeah and she was like ah
happy birthday i wanted to keep it a
secret i'm like this is bigger than my
room like how the how the [ __ ] were you
expecting to hide this
yeah and then i opened it it was the
[ __ ] berserk figure that was great
bro
well that's crazy
yeah i haven't really given any massive
gifts just because like i don't think
the occasion's come up yeah yeah what my
mum's have you ever had a moment where
you gave a gift and you're like damn
this is a good [ __ ] feeling right
every time i give a gift gone okay every
time every time i don't ever give
somebody i don't miss
always go over that high every time i
get a bottle of
needed